metal I hope you got that some links  links you know what in America this is  called ax um yeah and um I was wondering  why they did call ax so what I'm  thinking for this video will pop that  down give you that I'll give you that oh  you see what happens  don't try this at home don't  well that were to treat but I think I  want to see it a bit slower  let's do it again at five thousand  frames a second yeah yeah sweet what  really yep  [Music]  [Music]  just vanishes this is nothing left of it  and there's the top part that must be  where the axe went let's right through  the links sure smells good  where's the other bit of mystery was a  bit there does that through the last  time the old one we can't find two bits  [Music]